lawn darts is an extreme outdoor sport
it's like horseshoes but with pointy
stainless steel spigots it's the most
dangerous object in the office this
month all you need are some rings and
some lon one large ring and one small
ring go here the other ring is placed
approximately 40 feet away stand with
one foot in the ring and toss the dart
underhand you get three points for you
start in the inner ring two points for
you start in the outer ring and one
point for whoever gets closest to the
outer ring by the way lawn darts are
illegal in the US they were outlawed in
1988 after too many skull punctures you
can still import them from the UK